with just one year to go
anticipation is building across the
district as stadium waimakariri starts
to take shape
the mia and councillors toured the site
last week alongside staff from the north
canterbury sport and recreation trust
who will be responsible for managing the
facility
once construction is complete
mayor dan gordon says it was wonderful
to be able to walk through the building
and get a sense of what the finnish
stadium will be like
it's really good to have come through
and have a sneak preview of
where this project's at as we can see a
lot of people have been talking about it
as they've
gone past on cold stream road and seen
the framing go up
it's looking fantastic i understand it's
well on track
and the contractors are certainly making
a good job of it as we can see
it's going to be a terrific asset to our
community this facility for
ports with all the other services that
will be here including a
gymnasium as well so it's good to see
progress and
good to see the contractors are doing
such a good job on behalf of our
community
the 28 million multi-use sports facility
will be approximately 6 000 square
meters in size
and house four indoor courts as well as
a central fitness facility
changing rooms coaching and meeting
spaces and seating for up to 500
spectators
designed by warren and mani architects
it aims to become a vibrant focus point
for sport in the district
the stadium can also easily be expanded
in the future if required
the site on cold stream road places it
near other sporting grounds
such as the main power oval main power
hockey turf
and maria andrews park
despite a small delay due to the covert
19 lockdown
construction is on schedule it's
expected that the stadium's doors will
open to the public towards the end of
july
[Music]
2021
you